maintenant le film de ce drame nous
allons remonter donc à hier soir 19h10
au moment du choc dans la gare
souterraine de paris lyon quand le melun
paris a percuté un train de banlieue qui
devait rejoindre lui maisons alfort un
tel accident suppose bien sûr que l'on
n'est plus dans la normale des choses
au total aucun système de sécurité n'a
pu fonctionner il n'a même pas été
possible de dévier le train qui entrait
en gare sur une voie de garage
hervé brusini violence du choc le train
percuté s'est ouvert en deux entre ses
flancs il y à la motrice du paris melun
19h04 y hier la rame en instance de
départ pour villeneuve saint georges va
s'ébranler avec quelques minutes de
retard les voitures sont bondées des
voyageurs des employés la sncf aussi
aperçoivent un convoi qui arrive sur eux
à vive allure
ils n'ont que le temps de sauter hors
des voitures dans le paris melun le chef
du train a prévenu les passagers de
l'imminence d'une collision
voici le témoignage d'une rescapée elle
se trouvait dans la voiture qui était en
poney après on avait plein de pas
pouvoir en sortir mais il y avait
tellement de gens qui étaient plus
coincé que moi encore il y avait un
monsieur qui était sur mon dos et
oublier qu'il pouvait plus respirer
c'est petit bougé sam écrasait un peu
plus j'ai pas même dix mois fausse bouge
évidemment s'il y avait quand même deux
de retard il y aurait eu moins de monde
dans ce train là du fait du retail a été
créé allant de 2 trains aura seul train
c'est pour ça qu'on était nombre qui
avait une petite grand mère qui était
monté avec sa petite fille et qui avait
dit ça soit vraiment au fond local était
contre la maîtrise je pense qu'elle a
pas pu en sortir
je connaissais pas mais enfin ce concept
petite fille j'ai beaucoup d'enfants les
c'est l'image que vous garderez par
chance cette femme là qu une côte cassée
hier soir l'émotion était également
partagé par toutes les personnalités qui
se sont rendus sur les lieux
[Musique]